If you grew up in a big city, you may have heard the urban legend alligators in the sewers. They got there when people brought back baby alligators from vacations in Florida and flushed them down the toilets. That's the kind of thing that, once you turn 12, you don't believe in anymore.
如果你在大城市长大，可能听过下水道里有短吻鳄的都市传说。据说那是人们从佛罗里达度假回来带回幼鳄，然后把它们冲进马桶后形成的。这就是那种你一旦过了12岁就不会再相信的事情。
Well, New York Times , February 10, 1935, reports three teenagers were shoveling snow into a manhole on East 123rd Street. They look down and see an alligator, which they pull out. It's not very healthy. And they carry it to the Lehigh Stove and Repair Shop at 441 East 123rd. Lots of neighbors witness it. People are quoted by name. Best guess? The gator came off a boat in the Harlem River.
好吧，《纽约时报》1935年2月10日的报道称，三名青少年在东123街向一个人孔里铲雪。他们向下看时发现了一条短吻鳄，于是把它拉了出来。它看起来不太健康。他们把它带到了东123街441号的利哈伊炉具维修店。许多邻居目睹了这一幕。人们甚至被记名引用。最好的猜测是，这条鳄鱼是从哈莱姆河的一艘船上掉下来的。
Or, take this urban legend. I'd heard this one, but I'd never believed it. Turns out to be true. Ian Meyer in Portland, Oregon, three years ago, walks home one night with his girlfriend from a party, where he'd had a couple of beers, three beers. Gets to his house, goes in the bathroom
又或者，看看这个都市传说。我听说过这个，但从来没相信过。结果证明是真的。三年前，俄勒冈州波特兰市的伊恩·迈耶（Ian Meyer）一天晚上和女友从派对回家，他在那儿喝了几杯啤酒，三杯。到了家，他走进浴室。
Start unzipping with one hand, lifting the lid with the other hand, and, you know, I get the lid maybe halfway open. And there was this wet, beady-eyed rat in the toilet just looking up at me.
一只手拉开拉链，另一只手掀开盖子，你知道，盖子大概打开了一半。马桶里有一只湿漉漉的、长着豆粒般小眼睛的老鼠，正抬头看着我。
Right? Maybe you heard stories like this that don't seem they could possibly be true about somebody. They go in their bathroom late at night. They sit down. They get bit by a rat that came up through the pipes into the toilet. Here it is.
对吧？也许你也听过这种关于某人的、听起来根本不可能成真的故事。他们深夜走进浴室。坐下。结果被一只通过管道爬进马桶的老鼠咬了。这就是了。
The lid was down, so he must have come up through the sewer pipe somehow and swum through the lines and popped up into our toilet.
盖子是盖上的，所以它一定是穿过了下水道管道，游过了管线，然后钻进了我们的马桶。
Was the rat trying to get out of the toilet?
那只老鼠是在试图从马桶里出来吗？
No, I think he was just as-- almost as stunned as I was. No, he was just sort of perched in the bowl, looking up when I opened the lid.
不，我想它和我一样震惊。不，当我打开盖子时，它只是蹲在马桶里，抬头看着我。
OK. Horrifying. Ian, of course, quickly closes the lid, stands there dumbstruck. What's his next move? It's obvious.
好吧。太可怕了。当然，伊恩迅速盖上盖子，目瞪口呆地站在那里。他下一步该怎么做？显而易见。
I took a minute, gathered myself, and then flushed. Cracked the lid just a little bit, and he's still there. He's just more wet now, and he's probably a little more alert now.
我花了一分钟调整了一下，然后冲了水。把盖子掀开一点缝，它还在那儿。它现在更湿了，而且可能也更警觉了。
Now he's mad.
现在它生气了。
Yeah, now he's ready to get out of there. He's ready to take action.
是的，它准备离开那里了。它准备采取行动了。
Ian picks up the magazine rack by the toilet, which is heavy with three-years-old National Geographics . He puts this on top of the toilet lid, leaves the bathroom to figure out his next play. His girlfriend, Chelsea, is outside.
伊恩拿起马桶边上的杂志架，上面堆满了三年前的《国家地理》，很重。他把架子放在马桶盖上，离开浴室去思考下一步。他的女友切尔西在外面。
I don't want to kill the rat because I've never killed an animal. It should be easy enough to just catch him and let him go outside.
我不想杀这只老鼠，因为我从来没杀过动物。把它抓住然后放生到外面应该很容易。
Sure
当然。
What I told myself that I needed in order to accomplish that plan, one, was some music. I had to--
为了完成这个计划，我告诉自己需要做的第一件事是：放点音乐。我必须……
Really? That was step one? OK.
真的吗？那是第一步？好吧。
That was step one actually. And that was Chelsea's job. She had to turn some loud music on. This was kind of to psych me up.
那确实是第一步。那是切尔西的任务。她得放些响亮的音乐。这是为了给我打气。
[LOUD MUSIC PLAYING]
[播放响亮的音乐]
Ian puts a leather garden glove on one hand and puts a rubber kitchen glove on top of that figuring, the rat's wet, that's going to be better.
伊恩在一只手上戴了一只皮园艺手套，在上面又戴了一只橡胶厨房手套，心想老鼠是湿的，这样会好些。
So I gear up, go in the bathroom, shut the door. And then I guess I must've just kind of stood in there for five minutes or so because the next thing I know, Chelsea has the music turned down, and she's asking me, what's going on in there. I don't know what she thought had gone on, but she was worried and was checking on me, making sure that everything was OK. And once she checked on me I think that kind of triggered the man instinct, like, OK, come on dude, get it together.
于是我全副武装，走进浴室，关上门。我想我一定在里面站了五分钟左右，因为接下来我知道的就是，切尔西把音乐关小了，问我在里面干什么。我不知道她以为发生了什么，但她很担心，在检查我，确保一切都好。一旦她查看我，我想这激发了男人的本能，就像是，好吧，伙计，振作起来。
Yeah, time for some pride.
是的，是时候挽回尊严了。
It's just a rat. At this point, I take the magazine rack off of the toilet lid, crack the seat, and, somehow, before I know it, he's halfway out of the toilet.
那只是一只老鼠。这时，我从马桶盖上拿开杂志架，把坐便盖掀开一条缝，不知怎么的，在我反应过来之前，它已经半个身子冲出了马桶。
Not good. Ian drops the lid, leans his weight on it, which catches the rat half-in half-out of the toilet. Its head and front arms are sticking out, waving around. Now he just feels sorry for the little thing. But this is his chance to set it free.
不妙。伊恩放下盖子，用体重压住，把老鼠半截卡在马桶里。它的头和前肢露在外面，不停地挥舞。现在他反而同情这个小东西了。但这正是放走它的机会。
And so I'm thinking, OK perfect, I've got him caught here. He can't move anywhere. I'll reach down, grab him, carry out the plan. Right when I reach down, he bites me. He bites my finger.
我心想，太完美了，我把它抓住了。它哪儿也去不了。我伸手去抓它，执行计划。就在我伸手时，它咬了我。它咬了我的手指。
I'll spare you the gory details that follow. Let's just say that after another couple grabs, Ian comes to realize that he cannot capture the rat. He's going to have to kill him while he's trapped there halfway out of the toilet bowl. Which Ian does with his not-bare hands.
接下来的血腥细节我就不说了。只能说，在又试了几次之后，伊恩意识到他抓不住这只老鼠。他不得不把它困在马桶口处时杀掉它。伊恩用他的双手（虽然戴着手套）做到了这一点。
It was terrifying for months after that, maybe a year after that. Chelsea and I, we would just be extremely paranoid about sitting on the toilet especially at night.
那之后的好几个月，也许是一年，这让我感到恐惧。我和切尔西对坐在马桶上变得极其多疑，尤其是在晚上。
Ian says half the people he tells this story to don't believe it. He thinks they just don't want to believe it. But it turns out that the pipes that lead from your house to the sewer are not full of water. They're mostly empty unless you're doing your wash or something else that's sending a lot of water down.
伊恩说，他告诉过的人里有一半不相信。他认为他们只是不想相信。但事实证明，从你家通往污水管道的管子里并没有充满水。它们大部分是空的，除非你正在洗衣服或做其他大量排水的事情。
So rats can climb up through the pipes, and the only time that they actually need to hold their breath is when they get into the little reservoir in the toilet trap. In a way, it's surprising it doesn't happen more often. Ian says he's found another rat in his toilet since then. He now flushes when he walks into the bathroom just to send water down the pipes as a precaution against vermin. As for Chelsea?
所以老鼠可以爬过管道，它们唯一需要屏住呼吸的时候，就是进入马桶存水弯的小水槽时。从某种程度上说，这种情况没有更频繁地发生反而令人惊讶。伊恩说从那以后他又在马桶里发现过一只老鼠。他现在走进浴室时会先冲水，以作为防止害虫的预防措施。至于切尔西呢？
I think it was worse for Chelsea because she didn't actually really ever see the rat in the toilet. I got to see it, and I came to terms with it somewhat. For her, it was just-- it was still just sort of a myth.
我想对切尔西来说更糟，因为她其实从没亲眼看到过马桶里的老鼠。我看到了，我多少接受了现实。对她来说，那仍然只是个神话。
Chelsea was left with the urban legend that rats could come up into the toilet. I mean, now she knew it was true. So when she went into the bathroom, her imagination could just go wild.
切尔西依然被老鼠能爬进马桶这个都市传说所困扰。我的意思是，现在她知道是真的了。所以每当她走进浴室，她的想象力就会不受控制。
Well, today on our radio show, we tried to wave away the smoky vapor of illusion and myth. We dive into a few stories, a few urban myths to see what is real and what is not so our imaginations don't have to run wild anymore. From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life distributed by Public Radio International. We bring you today three stories of real urban legends.
今天在我们的广播节目中，我们试图驱散幻想和神话的烟雾。我们深入挖掘了一些故事，一些都市传说，看看哪些是真实的，哪些不是，这样我们的想象力就不必再肆意奔跑了。这里是来自芝加哥WBEZ的《美国生活》（This American Life），由国际公共广播电台发行。今天我们为您带来三个真实的都市传说故事。
Act One, What's That Smell, in which a retired millionaire tries to understand the reality of a tough, seedy inner city neighborhood. Act Two, Fleeing Is Believing. Foreigners come to the US who believe all kinds of misinformation about us that turns out to be true. Act Three, Sleeper Cells. Is it an urban myth that your cell phone gives you brain tumors? Stay with us.
第一幕，《那是什么味儿》，讲述了一位退休百万富翁试图理解一个艰难、破败的内城区社区的现实。第二幕，《逃离即相信》。外国人来到美国，相信了各种关于我们的错误信息，结果发现竟然是真的。第三幕，《沉睡细胞》。手机会导致脑瘤是一个都市传说吗？请继续收听。
What's that smell? The way Steve Poizner sees it, he did something admirable, something daring, something unusual. And when I read his account of what he did, he seemed sincere about it too. He's a bit of a corny writer. Though even that, you can kind of forgive him. He's not a professional author.
那是什么味儿？在史蒂夫·波兹纳（Steve Poizner）看来，他做了一件令人钦佩、大胆且不同寻常的事。当我读到他关于此事的叙述时，他看起来也很真诚。他是一个有点俗气的作家。尽管即使是这点，你也可以原谅他。毕竟他不是职业作家。
At the age of 45, after starting one Silicon Valley company that he sold for $30 million and a second one that sold for $1 billion, Poizner didn't need to work anymore. He says, he wanted to do some good for people. And so he called a dozen public high schools and volunteered to be a guest teacher of some sort. One called him back, a high school called Mount Pleasant. And Poizner got into his car, drove the 15 miles from his neighborhood in Los Gatos in Silicon Valley to East San Jose.
45岁时，在创立了一家以3000万美元售出的硅谷公司，以及第二家以10亿美元售出的公司后，波兹纳不再需要工作了。他说，他想为人们做点好事。于是他给十几所公立高中打了电话，自愿担任客座教师。一所叫芒特普莱森特（Mount Pleasant）的高中回电了。波兹纳坐上车，开车15英里，从硅谷洛斯加托斯的社区前往东圣何塞。
I passed nearby my neighborhood French bakery and the local Ferrari dealership.
我经过了我社区附近的法式面包店和当地的法拉利经销商。
This is Steve Poizner reading from the book he wrote about this.
这是史蒂夫·波兹纳在朗读他为此书写的书。
"Several miles and a couple of highways later, I took the Capitol Expressway exit and drove into what felt like another planet. Signs advertising janitorial supply stores and taquerias. Exhaust hung over 10 lanes of inner city traffic. Yellowing, weedy gardens fronted many of the homes, as did driveways marred by large oil spots or broken-down cars."
“几英里和几条高速公路后，我从国会高速公路出口驶出，开进了一个感觉像是另一个星球的地方。到处是广告招牌，写着清洁用品店和墨西哥卷饼店。废气笼罩着10车道的内城区交通。许多房屋前面是发黄的、长满杂草的花园，车道上布满了大片油渍或报废汽车。”
When he sees the sound walls that separate California homes from the highway, he asks, were they keeping out the city's grit and noise or hiding profoundly sad lives? He's allowed in the school to teach one US government class for one semester under another teacher's supervision.
当他看到将加州住宅与高速公路隔开的隔音墙时，他问，它们是在挡住城市的污垢和噪音，还是在掩盖极其悲惨的生活？他被允许在学校教一学期的美国政府课，但需要另一位老师的监督。
What  he finds in the school are leaky roofs, hardened, unresponsive students, gangs and violence, a drop-out rate twice the national average. He worries that one student is going to punch him. And later, that this student and his thug friends are going to push him up against a wall. He wonders if the students are "too busy ducking bullets to consider their careers." At the end of his first visit to school, he's relieved to find his Lexus still in the parking lot where he left it.
他在学校里发现的是漏水的屋顶、冷漠叛逆的学生、帮派和暴力，辍学率是全国平均水平的两倍。他担心有学生会打他。后来，又担心这个学生和他的暴徒朋友会把他推到墙上。他怀疑学生们是否“忙着躲避子弹，以至于没空考虑职业生涯”。在第一次访问学校结束时，他庆幸地发现他的雷克萨斯还停在停车场。
"The shadows grew longer and the surroundings became a bit scary. Opening the door to my car, I notice a residential street just over the school's parking lot's fence. There was an old Cadillac resting on two flat tires, something smelled rotten like trash that had sat around for too long, and a dog's raspy bark sounded uncomfortably close."
“阴影越来越长，周围的环境变得有点可怕。打开车门时，我注意到学校停车场围栏外有一条居民街道。有一辆旧凯迪拉克停在两个瘪轮胎上，空气中弥漫着像垃圾放置太久后的腐臭味，还有一种令人不安的、沙哑的狗叫声在附近响起。”
And the only problem with this is a lot of it might not be true.
唯一的问题是，很多内容可能并不属实。
Good evening. Steve Poizner released a new book today. It is about his time as a substitute teacher at a high school in East San Jose. And what he put in print is drawing a lot of heat. ABC7's Lisa Amin Gulezian is live tonight to explain.
晚上好。史蒂夫·波兹纳今天发布了一本新书。书的内容是他作为东圣何塞一所高中代课老师的经历。他写进书里的内容引发了强烈反响。ABC7电视台的丽莎·阿明·古莱西安（Lisa Amin Gulezian）今晚为您现场解读。
Steve Poizner's book got more attention than most do because in the seven years since he spent one semester at Mount Pleasant High School, Steve Poizner ran for assemblyman and lost, ran for a statewide office, California Insurance Commissioner, and won. He's in his fourth year in that job now. And today, he's one of two front-runners to become the Republican candidate for the governor of California. And right after publication, his book, which is titled Mount Pleasant, jumped to number 5 on The New York Times Best Seller list.
史蒂夫·波兹纳的书比大多数书更受关注，因为在他结束在芒特普莱森特高中任教的一个学期后的七年里，史蒂夫·波兹纳竞选过州议员但落选了，之后又竞选了加州保险局局长并胜选。他现在已经在任第四个年头了。而今天，他是竞选加州州长的共和党候选人的两位领跑者之一。新书发布后，《芒特普莱森特》一书直接冲上了《纽约时报》畅销书排行榜第5名。
Mount Pleasant High School students, teachers, parents, and alumni are outraged.
芒特普莱森特高中的学生、老师、家长和校友都感到愤怒。
Tonight, we are here to denounce Steve Poizner's comments.
今晚，我们来到这里是要谴责史蒂夫·波兹纳的评论。
Well, you know, it got very heated inside of Barnes and Noble before Steve Poizner's book signing. Eddie Garcia, the president of the East Side Union School Board, got in Poizner's face, challenging him about things that are written inside Mount Pleasant.
好吧，在史蒂夫·波兹纳的签售会开始前，巴诺书店（Barnes and Noble）里火药味十足。东区联合校董会主席埃迪·加西亚（Eddie Garcia）直面波兹纳，就书中的内容向他提出质疑。
I heard about Steve Poizner and the controversy over whether his book got things wrong when a publicist for the book contacted our radio program. She wrote an email describing the incident at the bookstore this way, "Liberal activist took offense at how he describes the school, accurately, as plagued by gangs, teen pregnancy, and disrepair. They are trying to shut him up and discredit his argument about charter schools." Poizner makes a case for charter schools late in the book. "This is a classic case of liberals refusing to listen to simple facts and rational solutions."
当这本书的公关人员联系我们的广播节目时，我听说了史蒂夫·波兹纳以及关于他书里内容是否失实的争议。她发的一封邮件这样描述了书店发生的冲突：“自由派活动家对他描述学校——准确地说，是饱受帮派、青少年怀孕和失修之苦——的方式感到冒犯。他们试图让他闭嘴，并抹黑他关于特许学校的观点。”波兹纳在书的后半部分为特许学校提出了论据。“这是一个典型的自由派拒绝听取简单事实和合理解决方案的案例。”
So I read the excerpt of his book online. There's a full chapter, and Poizner links to it from his campaign website. You can read it yourself. And it raised more questions than it answered. It's a very odd chapter, all about Poizner's first days teaching a class at Mount Pleasant. There's scene after scene where he's floundering, standing in front of the class asking big, abstract questions. "Would you want to live in a country where the leader didn't want to lead, if the money issued by the government wasn't any good, or people were treated unfairly?" None of the students respond.
于是我在网上读了书的节选。书里有完整的一章，波兹纳在他的竞选网站上有链接。你可以亲自阅读。它引发的问题比答案更多。这是非常奇怪的一章，讲的全是波兹纳在芒特普莱森特教书头几天的情景。书中一幕接着一幕，写他如何笨拙、如何站在教室前问一些宏大且抽象的问题。“你们想生活在一个领导者不想领导的国家吗？如果政府发行的钱不值钱了，或者人们受到不公平对待了会怎样？”学生们毫无反应。
He's a rookie teacher. He doesn't know how to engage them yet. Nothing unusual there. But here's the strange thing. The conclusion Poizner comes to, again and again, during these scenes isn't that he's doing anything wrong, or he has anything to learn as a teacher. Instead, he blames the kids. They're tough. They're unmotivated. They lack ambition. They're wired differently.
他是个菜鸟老师。他还不知道如何引导学生。这没什么不正常的。但奇怪的是，波兹纳在这些场景中反复得出的结论并不是他做错了什么，也不是作为老师他还有什么要学的。相反，他指责孩子们。他们顽固、没有动力、缺乏抱负。他们的思维方式不同。
The students, meanwhile, in every scene in the book-- I've read the whole book-- seem utterly lovely. Polite, they don't interrupt, they don't talk back. They just seem a little bored. His very worst student is a graduating senior, who's hoping to go into the Marines. Checking school records, I learn that Poizner's unmotivated, unambitious class included one of the school valedictorians, Charles Rudy, who graduated and went to college.
与此同时，书里的每个场景——我读了全书——学生们看起来都非常可爱。很有礼貌，他们不打断发言，也不顶嘴。他们只是看起来有点无聊。他最差劲的学生是一个即将毕业的高三生，他希望能加入海军陆战队。查阅学校记录后，我发现波兹纳所谓的缺乏动力、没有抱负的学生班级里，竟然有一位学校的毕业生代表，查尔斯·鲁迪（Charles Rudy），他毕业后进入了大学。
Could he be getting this so completely wrong, I wondered? Could he have written an entire book misperceiving so thoroughly what was happening in front of his own eyes and was now trying to use that book to run for governor? It seemed too incredible. And that's what brought me to San Jose last week to visit the school and its neighborhood.
我心想，他真的能把事实扭曲得这么彻底吗？他写了一整本书，完全误读了发生在眼前的事情，现在还想利用这本书去竞选州长？这太不可思议了。这促使我上周前往圣何塞参观那所学校及其周边社区。
My eyes were rolling throughout the entire book.
我读完整本书时简直翻白眼翻到头痛。
This is Joe Lovato. He teaches English at Mount Pleasant. His Dad taught English at Mount Pleasant before him.
这是乔·洛瓦托（Joe Lovato）。他在芒特普莱森特教英语。他的父亲在他之前也在这儿教英语。
Well, in the book, he tells stories of crossing the valley from his local Ferrari dealership, past his local French bakery, crossing town, getting off the freeway into my neighborhood and passing the taquerias and then wondering about the profoundly sad lives of the people who live behind the sound walls along the highway there. That's me. I live there. I can tell you, I have the white picket fence. I have two--
书里他讲述了自己如何跨过山谷，从当地的法拉利车行出发，经过法式面包店，穿过城镇，驶出高速公路来到我所在的社区，经过墨西哥卷饼店，然后怀疑住在高速公路隔音墙后的那些人过着极其悲惨的生活。那就是我。我就住在那儿。我可以告诉你，我有白色篱笆。我有两……
Literally?
真的吗？
Yeah, literally. A very well-manicured lawn. My Infiniti is in the front. And I've got a real cute dog. I've got two kids running around in the front yard with my wife chasing them around.
是的，真的。精心修剪的草坪。前院停着我的英菲尼迪。我还有一条非常可爱的狗。我的妻子带着两个孩子在前院跑来跑去。
The derogatory statements to our students, the inaccuracies, the exaggerations, that's the part we're upset about.
那些贬低我们学生的声明、失实之处、夸大其词，这些才是让我们感到愤怒的地方。
Mark Holston is one of Joe's colleagues in the English department. In his book, Poizner talks a few times about wishing that he could have a Stand and Deliver moment with his students. And Mark says, that's a problem right there.
马克·霍尔斯顿（Mark Holston）是乔在英语系的同事。在书中，波兹纳几次提到希望自己能像《为人师表》（Stand and Deliver）里那样拥有辉煌的时刻。马克说，这正是问题所在。
There's a narrative he had in his mind. He saw teacher movies, and that was the narrative he had. And it fits his narrative to show that this school is a horrible school. I wouldn't work at the school he described. I'd be afraid to work in the school that he described in the thing. It's almost like he's stepping over bodies, and there's gun shots as he goes to his classroom every day.
他脑子里有一套叙事。他看过老师题材的电影，那是他头脑中的叙事。为了证明这是一所糟糕的学校，这种叙事非常符合他的目的。我才不会在那种学校工作呢。如果学校真像他描述的那样，我根本不敢在那儿待。那描述仿佛每天去教室的路上都要跨过尸体，到处是枪响。
And it's completely inaccurate, but it fits his narrative. It fits promoting himself for the governor. And if anybody hasn't-- and some people say, well, it's not true, we know it's not true, it's exaggeration. But anybody else outside of East San Jose reads this book, that's the truth.
这完全不属实，但这符合他的叙事。这符合他为竞选州长做宣传的目的。而且，如果有人没去过——有些人说，嗯，这不是真的，我们知道这不是真的，这是夸张。但任何东圣何塞以外的人读到这本书，就会把它当成事实。
Driving around the neighborhood, it is hard to disagree with the teachers who say that it is a perfectly nice middle class and working class area. Occasionally you'll see a house in bad shape, but overwhelmingly it's nicely tended yards, garages, decent cars and SUVs in the driveways. It's suburban. I was surprised to learn that when Poizner taught here in 2003, there was a golf course just a couple blocks from the school. There's still a lake and the Raging Waters water park. He doesn't mention those in the book.
开车绕着社区转了一圈，很难不同意那些老师的观点：这是一个完全舒适的中产阶级和工人阶级社区。偶尔你会看到一栋房子维护不善，但绝大多数房屋拥有打理得很好的庭院、车库，车道上停着体面的轿车和SUV。这就是郊区。我惊讶地发现，波兹纳2003年在这儿任教时，离学校几个街区远就有一个高尔夫球场。现在还有一个湖和一个名为“狂暴水域”（Raging Waters）的水上乐园。他在书里只字未提。
We called a half dozen local real estate agents who confirmed what the teachers told us. That the neighborhood looks the same today as it did back in 2003. If anything, they said, with the recession, it's gotten a little worse. Average house price in 2003 near the school was $457,000. Today, it's $317,000.
我们联系了半打当地房地产经纪人，他们证实了老师们的话。社区今天看起来和2003年时没什么两样。他们说，甚至因为经济衰退，情况稍微差了一点点。2003年学校附近的平均房价是45.7万美元。今天则是31.7万美元。
Well, it's 4:45, and I'm standing in the staff parking lot where Steve Poizner used to park his car, I suppose. And I am hearing the raspy sound of a dog's bark. I can't see any beat-up, old cars over the fence. Mainly, it's incredibly lush and green and beautiful. There are little purple flowers. There are palm trees. And it's just-- it's lovely. And it smells nice. Though there is the dumpster for the school right by the parking lot. Conceivably, on some day that he was out here, that's what was making the trash smell was the school's own trash.
现在是4点45分，我正站在史蒂夫·波兹纳以前停车的停车场。我听到了那种沙哑的狗叫声。我没看到围栏外有什么破旧的旧车。这里主要是郁郁葱葱、非常绿色和美丽的景象。有紫色的小花。有棕榈树。这里真的很可爱。闻起来也很香。虽然停车场旁边确实有个学校的垃圾箱。可以想象，在他来这里的某一天，那种垃圾臭味可能就是学校自己的垃圾发出来的。
Now we went to the neighborhood and were told it hasn't changed that much since 2003 when you were there and--
我们去过那个社区，他们告诉我们，自从你2003年在那儿以后，社区并没有太大变化，并且……
So I ran all this by Steve Poizner, the tidy houses, the golf course, what I did not smell in the parking lot.
于是我把这一切都告诉了史蒂夫·波兹纳，那些整洁的房子、高尔夫球场，以及我在停车场没闻到的味道。
Are you overplaying the desperate poverty of this neighborhood?
你是不是夸大了这个社区绝望的贫困程度？
No, I don't think so. I mean, it's definitely not like some inner city areas. And I don't know what-- what you described doesn't strike me as the neighborhood I was at. I mean, at least in 2002 and 2003. I mean, the neighborhood is rough and tumble in that there's definitely a lot of crime and, no question, lower income. And there's a lot of signs that people were struggling economically.
不，我不这么认为。我的意思是，它绝对不像某些内城区。我不知道……你所描述的并不像我所待的那个社区。至少在2002年和2003年是这样。我的意思是，那个社区确实充满了混乱和冲突，毫无疑问有很多犯罪，收入也较低。有很多迹象表明人们在经济上苦苦挣扎。
That's why the crime statistics for surrounding the school, you can get those from the San Jose Police Department like I did. And we definitely documented that not only did it appear to be kind of a rough up-and-coming area, but the police will tell you that too.
这就是为什么，你可以像我一样从圣何塞警察局获取学校周围的犯罪统计数据。我们可以确凿地证明，它不仅看起来是一个破败且正在走下坡路的区域，而且警察也会告诉你同样的事。
So we went to the police. And they informed us that no, the neighborhood around Mount Pleasant High School is not especially dangerous or crime ridden. It's average for San Jose. And while San Jose might have a reputation in the richer suburbs around it for being sketchy and definitely was more dangerous in the '70s and '80s, a police spokesman told us that that view is out of date, an urban myth.
于是我们去了警察局。他们告知我们，芒特普莱森特高中周围的社区并不是特别危险或犯罪猖獗。在圣何塞属于平均水平。虽然圣何塞周围较富裕的郊区可能有一种名声，认为这里很危险，而且在70年代和80年代确实更乱，但一位警方发言人告诉我们，这种观点已经过时了，纯属都市传说。
According to FBI statistics, San Jose is one of the safest cities in the country. There are 371 violent crimes per 100,000 people in San Jose in 2003, the year Poizner was there. You'd be more likely to be a victim of violent crime in Austin, Texas or Seattle or Phoenix or Columbus, Ohio or San Francisco. When it came to property crime that year, you were more than twice as likely to have something stolen from you in Honolulu, Denver, Seattle, San Francisco or nearly any big city you can name.
根据FBI统计数据，圣何塞是全国最安全的城市之一。2003年波兹纳在那儿时，圣何塞每10万人中有371起暴力犯罪。如果你在德克萨斯州奥斯汀、西雅图、菲尼克斯、俄亥俄州哥伦布或旧金山，遭遇暴力犯罪的可能性更高。在财产犯罪方面，那一年你在檀香山、丹佛、西雅图、旧金山或几乎任何一个大城市被盗的可能性，是这里的两倍多。
In his book, Poizner plays up the violence at the school itself. He mentions a shooting at the school that happened all the way back in 1990 where a Vietnamese student from another school shot a Mount Pleasant freshman. And Poizner tells a story of a student of his who let him know that she wouldn't be at class for a couple of days because her boyfriend was on trial for being the driver in a bank robbery. There's another student in Poizner's class that Poizner assumes must be in a gang. Though confusingly in the book, Poizner never actually goes to the trouble to find out if the student is in a gang. That's the student who Poizner worries will hit him or get his thug friends and push him against a wall.
在书中，波兹纳大肆渲染学校内部的暴力。他提到了1990年发生的一起枪击案，当时另一所学校的一名越南裔学生枪击了一名芒特普莱森特的大一新生。波兹纳还讲了一个学生的故事，她说她会缺席几天，因为她的男朋友因涉及一起银行抢劫案正在接受审判。波兹纳的班里还有另一个学生，他断定对方一定是帮派成员。尽管让人困惑的是，在书里，波兹纳从来没费心去确认那个学生是否真的是帮派分子。那就是那个波兹纳担心会打他或者找暴徒朋友把他推到墙上的学生。
So is the school dangerous? Well, I checked with the man who knows, Christopher Schroeder, the associate principal at Mount Pleasant in charge of discipline.
那么学校危险吗？好吧，我咨询了最了解情况的人，克里斯托弗·施罗德（Christopher Schroeder），他是负责纪律的芒特普莱森特副校长。
There is a gang presence in the area. They've been here for-- we're into the second and sometimes third generation of gang families. We know this. But at school, we don't have gang problems per se. Our students are able to sit next to each other in a classroom and not have conflicts. We don't have fights in the classroom. We don't have fights on campus. We have few fights. Off the top of my head, I think we've had about a dozen fights this year.
该地区确实有帮派活动。他们已经在这里……我们已经进入了帮派家庭的第二代甚至第三代。我们知道这一点。但在学校里，我们并没有所谓的帮派问题。我们的学生可以在教室里并排坐着而不会发生冲突。我们的课堂上没有打架。校园里也没有打架。我们很少发生争执。我想了一下，今年大概只发生了十几起打架。
That's about the number of fights that you would get at any high school even in a fancy neighborhood. There are no metal detectors in the school's entrances. Mr. Schroeder says, the total number of gang members among the 1,900 students here? 50 at most.
这和你会在任何高中，甚至是富人区高中遇到的打架次数差不多。学校入口没有金属探测器。施罗德先生说，1900名学生中，帮派成员总数是多少？最多50个。
They are aware that we know who they are. But we also have gang intervention specialists who work with them every day. Almost every day, we have a gang intervention specialist out there with those guys, talking about their problems, talking about what's happening on the street, making sure that we have peace on campus.
他们知道我们了解他们的身份。但我们也有帮派干预专家每天与他们一起工作。几乎每一天，我们都有帮派干预专家和这些家伙待在一起，谈论他们的问题，谈论街头上发生的事，确保我们的校园和平。
When it comes to the drop out rate, Steve Poizner also seems to be choosing his statistics very selectively. Mount Pleasant's dropout rate, including the year he was there, is consistently better, sometimes far better than the state and national dropout rates, which is a huge achievement for a school like Mount Pleasant that is 2/3 Latino. Nationally, Latino dropout rates are much higher than those of other students. In his book, Poizner doesn't mention any of those numbers.
至于辍学率，史蒂夫·波兹纳似乎也在有选择地引用统计数据。芒特普莱森特的辍学率，包括他任教的那一年，始终优于甚至远优于州和全国的平均水平，这对一所2/3是拉丁裔学生的芒特普莱森特高中来说是一项巨大的成就。在全国范围内，拉丁裔的辍学率远高于其他学生。在书中，波兹纳对这些数字只字未提。
And he doesn't mention the school's stats at all, but instead quotes a number for the district that the school is in, the East Side Union High School District. Even here, he cherry-picks. In 2003, the year Poizner was at the district, its dropout rate was slightly lower than the state and national averages. Poizner instead chooses to quote the number for one of the two years during the past decade, 2005, when the district had twice as many dropouts as the state and national numbers. Statistically, Poizner did not teach at a terrible school in a terrible neighborhood, but an average school in an average neighborhood.
他根本没有提到学校的数据，而是引用了学校所在的“东区联合学区”的数据。即便是这里，他也是挑拣着引用的。2003年波兹纳在学区工作时，该区的辍学率略低于州和全国平均水平。波兹纳却选择了过去十年中仅有的两个年份之一（2005年）的数据，那一年该区的辍学人数是州和全国平均数的两倍。从统计学上讲，波兹纳并不是在恶劣社区的糟糕学校任教，而是在一个普通社区的普通学校。
[SINGING]
[歌声]
We got trouble.
我们有麻烦了。
Oh, we got trouble.
噢，我们有麻烦了。
Right here in River City.
就在这条河城。
With a capital T and that rhymes with P and that stands for pool.
以大写字母T开头，押韵P，代表台球。
That stands for pool.
代表台球。
We surely got trouble.
我们确实有麻烦了。
These are the dangerous toughs of Mount Pleasant High School rehearsing The Music Man in the brand new auditorium that the school just built. The school has 150 students studying animation in a special studio with rows of Macs and animation stands. This was all going on when Poizner was at the school too. There are 19 AP classes. There's a vocational program teaching metal and woodworking and computer-aided design plus a variety of special projects and programs to close the achievement gap and get less-priveleged kids to college. School attendance is 95%.
这些是芒特普莱森特高中的危险顽固分子，他们正在学校刚建好的崭新礼堂里排练《音乐人》（The Music Man）。学校有150名学生在一个拥有成排苹果电脑和动画架的特别工作室里学习动画。波兹纳在学校时，这一切也都在进行。学校有19门先修课程（AP）。这里还有职业课程，教授金属和木工、计算机辅助设计，以及各种旨在缩小成绩差距、让弱势群体孩子进入大学的特别项目。学校出勤率高达95%。
[STUDENTS HOLDING A FINAL NOTE]
[学生们坚持最后一个音符]
All right. "Iowa Stubborn." Everyone into place.
好的。“爱荷华顽固派。”各就各位。
Some things about the school though clearly could be better. The school doesn't hit its goals in statewide testing. It ranks in the 40th percentile of all California schools partly because a fourth of Mount Pleasant student body is rated "not proficient" in English. But measured against schools with similar demographics, it's in the 70th percentile.
不过学校有些地方显然可以更好。学校在全州测试中没有达到目标。它在所有加州学校中排名第40百分位，部分原因是芒特普莱森特四分之一的学生被评定为英语“不熟练”。但如果与人口结构相似的学校相比，它排在第70百分位。
For years, I was a reporter in the Chicago Public Schools for NPR's daily news programs. I've been in great schools. I've been in dangerous schools, urban schools, suburban schools. Mount Pleasant is definitely one of the better public high schools I've ever visited. And I know that it may seem like I'm belaboring all this, putting this one book under a microscope point by point, but so many of the political discussions in our country just seem so disconnected from reality. Every year, there are egregious examples of politicians and commentators who believe that if they repeat some non-fact over and over, it becomes true. And the more I looked into Poizner's book, the more it seemed like one of those rare cases that is so obviously and provably untrue.
多年来，我是美国国家公共电台（NPR）日常新闻节目的芝加哥公立学校记者。我去过很棒的学校，去过危险的学校，去过城市学校，去过郊区学校。芒特普莱森特绝对是我去过的最好的公立高中之一。我知道我可能有点小题大做，把这本书放在显微镜下逐点剖析，但我们国家太多的政治讨论似乎与现实脱节。每年都有政客和评论员的恶劣案例，他们相信只要不断重复某种不真实的事实，它就会变成真的。我对波兹纳的书研究得越深，它似乎就越像那种罕见的事例，明显地、可证明地虚假。
Though in Poizner's case, what made this especially interesting was that from his book, it seemed very possible that he really is just a well-meaning, idealistic guy who wants to help people who just got a lot of this wrong. Though when I asked Steve Poizner if that's what happened here, that it is not a dangerous, bad school, he stuck by his guns.
尽管在波兹纳的案例中，有趣的一点是，从他的书中看来，他很有可能真的是个善意、理想主义、想帮助别人却搞错了很多事情的人。然而当我问史蒂夫·波兹纳是否就是这种情况——即那并不是一所危险的坏学校时，他坚持自己的观点。
You write really honestly in the book about how you aren't from a neighborhood like this and how naive you are going in. I mean, you write really, really honestly about it. Do you think it's possible that you went into this neighborhood, and you just misperceived how dangerous and tough it is? And that's what people are pointing out?
你在书中非常诚实地写道你不是来自这样的社区，以及你进去时有多天真。我的意思是，你写得非常、非常诚实。你认为有没有可能你进入这个社区后，误判了它的危险和艰苦程度？而这正是人们指出的？
Well, most people who are reading the book, just don't have that reaction. There are some--
嗯，大多数读这本书的人并没有那种反应。有些……
Well, no, but I'm not talking about-- I'm talking about the people in the neighborhood, who know the neighborhood.
不，不，我不是在说……我是在说社区里那些了解这个社区的人。
I don't think it's a surprise that people who are in that neighborhood bristle at blunt observations.
我不认为身处那个社区的人对直白的观察感到恼火是什么新鲜事。
But do you think it's possible that--
但你认为有没有可能……
By the way, I just said--
顺便说一句，我刚说……
Do you think it's possible-- I mean, you talk so honestly about this in the book-- do you think it's possible that you just misperceived it because you weren't used to that kind of neighborhood?
你认为有没有可能——我的意思是，你在书中谈到这一点时非常诚实——你认为有没有可能你只是误判了它，因为你不习惯那种社区？
Well, this is a book about my experience. And so that's all the book is about based on my background.
嗯，这是一本关于我个人经历的书。所以这本书的内容完全基于我的背景。
So I'm taking it-- so are you saying you do think it's possible?
所以我在问——你是说你认为有可能吗？
This is the way I perceive it.
这就是我感知到的方式。
So you think it might be possible?
所以你认为有可能？
No, I'm not saying that.
不，我没这么说。
What upsets me from the beginning and even now is his intent.
从一开始到现在，让我感到困扰的是他的意图。
Again, English teacher Mark Holsten.
再次邀请英语老师马克·霍尔斯顿。
Soon after his experience at Mount Pleasant, he ran for assemblyman. And I think what kind of turned me off to him was I got some of his campaign literature, and on there he had, businessman/teacher based on his one semester teaching. And he claimed he was a teacher by profession. And right away, that's what kind of offended me. The centerpiece of his campaign was his experience at Mount Pleasant High School. Even in his commercials, he said, I've taught in schools, I know what it's like to work at the schools, I can fix the problems and things like that.
在芒特普莱森特的经历后不久，他竞选了州议员。我觉得让我对他反感的是，我收到了一些他的竞选宣传资料，上面写着“商人/教师”，这是基于他任教的那一个学期。他声称自己是职业教师。这立刻冒犯了我。他竞选的核心就是他在芒特普莱森特高中的经历。甚至在他的广告里，他也说，我在学校教过书，我知道在学校工作是什么感觉，我可以解决这些问题等等。
From my understanding, it was obvious that he was there to exploit our students, to exploit our school. He came there saying, he had no political ambitions. He told our principal, this is not about politics, I just want to give back to the community, I just want to see what it's like to teach in a school and get a better understanding what the schools are like. Even in his book, he says, I had no intention of running for office when I went there.
据我了解，很明显他是在那里利用我们的学生，利用我们的学校。他来到那儿时说自己没有政治野心。他告诉我们的校长，这与政治无关，我只想回馈社区，我只是想看看在学校教书是什么感觉，更深入地了解学校是什么样。即使在书里，他也说，我去那里时完全没有竞选公职的打算。
Poizner still insists on that. It was two months after he stopped teaching at the school that he filed papers to start fundraising to run for assemblyman. In the spring after that, his campaign came back to Mount Pleasant to shoot a commercial with testimony from teachers and students about what Poizner had done for the school. The videographer set up a camera and lights in one of the classrooms during seventh period. And students were ushered in one at a time.
波兹纳依然坚持这一点。但他停止教书两个月后，就提交了文件开始筹款竞选州议员。在那之后的春天，他的竞选团队回到芒特普莱森特，拍摄了一部广告，请老师和学生作证波兹纳为学校做了什么。摄像师在第七节课时把摄像机和灯光架在教室里。学生们被一个接一个地领进来。
In campaigning, including in one of his campaign biographies-- a biography which, by the way, calls Mount Pleasant "an inner city high school"-- Poizner also touts the fact that the principal of Mount Pleasant named him Rookie Teacher of the Year.
在竞选活动中，包括在他的一本竞选传记中——顺便说一句，那本传记将芒特普莱森特称为“内城区高中”——波兹纳还宣扬芒特普莱森特的校长评他为“年度最佳新秀教师”这一事实。
Oh, the Rookie of the Year thing, it was--
噢，那个“年度最佳新秀教师”的事，那是……
Mark Holston and Joe Lovato explained that at the end of school that year, the principal quickly wrote up a bunch of certificates on his computer for a staff party. Lots of people got them for all kinds of things.
马克·霍尔斯顿和乔·洛瓦托解释说，那一年学期末，校长在员工聚会上匆忙在电脑上写了一堆证书。很多人因为各种各样的事情都拿到了证书。
And that's the other part that really incensed me when he put out his press release as a result of his he received the Rookie of the Year award as if it was voted on statewide, and there was a board, and there was a panel, and essays were written about great he was. It was a certificate printed out. Everybody that was leaving was getting certificates. And that was a certificate of appreciation.
当他发布新闻稿声称自己获得了“年度最佳新秀教师”奖时，这确实激怒了我，仿佛这是全州投票选出的，有委员会，有评选团，还写了关于他有多棒的文章一样。那只是一张打印出来的证书。每个要离开的人都拿到了证书。那只是一份感谢证书。
The reason I've been wanting to talk to people about the book is just because I hate to see somebody's character get assassinated unfairly, which is my judgement that was what's been happening.
我之所以一直想和人们谈论这本书，是因为我不忍看到有人的人格被不公正地暗杀，这就是我认为正在发生的事情。
Todd Richards is the social studies teacher who supervised Steve Poizner in classroom 612 back in 2003. He's still there.
托德·理查兹（Todd Richards）是2003年史蒂夫·波兹纳在612教室任教时的社会学督导老师。他现在还在那儿。
Well, it's still largely as it would have been when Poizner was here. You can see there's the usual whiteboard in front. There's a screen for the LCD projector.
嗯，它基本上还是波兹纳在这里时的样子。你可以看到前面有常见的白板。还有LCD投影仪的屏幕。
In the debate among Mount Pleasant teachers over whether Steve Poizner was a Machiavellian schemer, who used them, or a sincere, perhaps slightly naive guy, who actually wanted to help out, Mr. Richards is a principled agnostic. We can't know what he was thinking, Richards says. So let's judge his actions. Richard says that he was as suspicious as anybody when this millionaire showed up in his classroom. But over the course of the year--
在芒特普莱森特老师们关于史蒂夫·波兹纳到底是利用他们的马基雅维利式阴谋家，还是一个真诚、也许有点天真、真的想帮忙的人的争论中，理查兹先生是一个有原则的不可知论者。理查兹说，我们无法知道他在想什么。所以让我们评判他的行为吧。理查兹说，当这位百万富翁出现在他的教室时，他也像其他人一样怀疑。但经过一年……
I came to think that he was someone who cared deeply about the students. I'd had people from the business world come in and really talk down to students, not put any effort into it, speak to them in jargon. I mean, it just-- I never want you back kind of thing. Poizner clearly worked very, very hard on this class. He was a rookie. He made rookie mistakes. But he clearly wanted the kids to have a valuable experience. And he clearly cared that they graduate and do well.
我开始认为他是一个深深关心学生的人。我见过来自商业界的人进来，真的以居高临下的态度对待学生，不投入任何精力，用行话对他们说话。我的意思是，那简直是……那种永远不想让你再回来的感觉。波兹纳显然在这个班级投入了非常、非常多的努力。他是个菜鸟。他犯了菜鸟错误。但他显然希望孩子们能有一次宝贵的经历。他显然关心他们是否毕业以及是否表现出色。
When I recorded Mr. Richards teaching a class, his sixth-period college-level macroeconomics class for seniors--
当我录制理查兹先生上课时，是他第六节针对高三学生的大学水平宏观经济学课……
So, C plus I plus G plus X minus M.
所以，C加I加G加X减M。
He asked me if I would like to take five minutes and ask a few questions of the students. He left the room, so his presence wouldn't bias anybody. I asked the class if there was anything that they would want me to ask Poizner on their behalf or to say to him. One senior raised his hand and said that he'd just heard from colleges.
他问我是否想花五分钟时间向学生们问几个问题。他离开了房间，这样他的在场就不会偏向任何人。我问班上的同学，有什么想让我代表他们问波兹纳或者对他说的。一名高三学生举手说，他刚收到大学录取通知。
I'm going to Berkeley. Take that Poizner.
我要去伯克利了。拿去吧，波兹纳。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
No, seriously. Because it's like how is he going to talk about us the way he did when we had almost nine people get into Berkley this year? That's ridiculous.
不，说真的。因为他怎么能那样谈论我们呢，我们今年有将近九个人被伯克利录取？那太荒谬了。
Yvette Rodriguez, another senior, spoke up.
另一位高三学生伊薇特·罗德里格斯（Yvette Rodriguez）发言了。
A lot of things that he said is something that you would expect someone who doesn't live in this neighborhood to think of us. He was just really quick to judge. He didn't grow up here. And he says it in his book. Where he grew up, they don't have any of this, so how is he just going to-- I'm not going to go judge him and say, oh, you know, he's like a rich white guy and doesn't know. Because I don't know him. But yet he's over here judging us. That's stereotyping. So I think he needs to come out and say-- apologize I think, at least, because a lot of us felt really offended by it.
他说了很多话，都是你期望那种不住在这个社区的人会想到的。他太容易评判人了。他不是在这里长大的。他在书里也说了。他长大的地方没有这些东西，所以他怎么能……我不会去评判他，说，噢，你知道，他是个富有的白人，什么都不懂。因为我不了解他。但他却在这里评判我们。那是刻板印象。所以我认为他需要站出来说——至少道个歉，因为我们很多人确实为此感到被冒犯了。
When I visited the school, I went to Mr. Richards' class. And I asked the students if they had questions for you or anything that they would like me to say to you. And they had one request. One senior girl said, she'd like you to admit you got things wrong. She'd like you to apologize. What do you want to say to her?
我去学校时去了理查兹先生的班上。我问学生们是否有什么问题想问你，或者有什么想让我转达给你的。他们有一个请求。一名高三女生说，她希望你承认你搞错了。她希望你道歉。你想对她说些什么？
Well, no. I appreciate her feedback. And I appreciate their passion. And by the way, it's been pretty interesting to see how much school spirit has emerged as some people at the school were concerned about whether their school was being fairly characterized.
嗯，不。我很感谢她的反馈。我也很感谢他们的热情。顺便说一句，看到当学校里有些人担心他们的学校是否被公平对待时，涌现出如此多的学校精神，这非常有趣。
Let's just step back for a second and just think about what I've done and what I'm doing. So here, I sell my last company for a lot of money. And I'm pretty financially well-off. And I decide to go into Mount Pleasant High School. And then after I teach at the school for an extended period of time, I then go back to the school every year to do guest teaching. And then my wife and I get all kinds of requests from teachers and students about certain projects. And we end up donating over $80,000 to the school over a period of many years. I love the school.
让我们退后一步，想想我做了什么以及我正在做什么。我卖掉了我的最后一家公司，赚了很多钱。我经济状况相当好。我决定去芒特普莱森特高中。在学校任教了很长一段时间后，我每年都会回到学校做客座教师。我和妻子还收到了老师和学生们关于某些项目的各种请求。在多年期间，我们最终向学校捐赠了超过8万美元。我热爱这所学校。
And then I write this book about my experiences at the school. And the purpose of the book-- even the critics at the school, I guess, seem to understand-- the purpose of the book is to zero in on the fact that Mount Pleasant High School is underperforming. Huge opportunities to improve. The school is in the bottom 40%. And I guess you can argue about my characterizations of the school. I stand by them. But no one seems to be arguing with the conclusions of the book.
然后我写了这本关于我在学校经历的书。这本书的目的——即使是学校里的批评者似乎也理解——这本书的目的是聚焦于芒特普莱森特高中表现不佳的事实。有巨大的提升机会。学校处于后40%。我想你可以对我对学校的描述有争议。我坚持我的描述。但似乎没有人对书中的结论提出异议。
Well, sort of. Some conclusions, obviously, people do argue with. But this particular conclusion-- that being at the 40th percentile among California public schools is not good enough-- is one that's kind of gotten lost in the shuffle in a lot of the discussion at the school.
嗯，算是有吧。有些人显然对结论有争议。但这个特定的结论——在加州公立学校中处于第40百分位是不够好的——在学校的许多讨论中有点被淹没了。
And that's the part that kind of frustrates me.
这就是让我感到沮丧的地方。
Sudhir Karandikar created the AP calculus program at Mount Pleasant. He teaches four classes of AP calculus. He's the only teacher I saw at school who could be described as dapper. And the only one wearing a suit, a charcoal gray pinstripe. He's been at Mount Pleasant 14 years. And he says, sure, Poizner got it wrong when he wrote that this is a dangerous school.
苏迪尔·卡兰迪卡（Sudhir Karandikar）在芒特普莱森特创建了AP微积分项目。他教四门AP微积分课。他是我在学校看到的唯一可以被描述为衣着考究的老师。也是唯一一个穿西装的，深灰色细条纹西装。他在芒特普莱森特待了14年。他说，当然，波兹纳在写这是一所危险学校时搞错了。
The whole ducking bullets and the kid is going to hit him and his Lexus is going to get stolen, it was either a gross exaggeration for the sake of making a dramatic book, or he just misread it. Let's move on. We know he got the safety issue wrong. As far as academic performance of this school, he was dead-on. Academically, I don't find anything wrong in his conclusions or assessments of our school academically.
什么躲避子弹、孩子要打他、雷克萨斯会被偷，要么是为了写一本戏剧性的书而进行的严重夸张，要么就是他读错了。让我们继续。我们知道他在安全问题上搞错了。至于学校的学业表现，他是完全准确的。在学术上，我发现他的结论或对我们学校的评估在学术方面没有任何问题。
"We should be doing a better job with these kids," Mr. Karandikar said. "That's what we should move the discussion to now." A few teachers told me that they agreed with Poizner, that academically the school should be better. And they like the fact that Poizner gives lots of details in his book to help his readers understand the money problems that the school faces and that he shows some of the everyday teaching problems they're up against, stuff that isn't really talked about in the news or normal political discussions about schools. Here's English teacher Vivian Bricksin.
“我们应该在这些孩子身上做得更好，”卡兰迪卡先生说。“这就是我们现在应该转入的讨论。”几位老师告诉我，他们同意波兹纳的观点，即从学术上讲，学校应该更好。他们喜欢波兹纳在书中提供了大量细节，帮助读者了解学校面临的资金问题，并展示了他们所面临的一些日常教学问题，这些在新闻或关于学校的常规政治讨论中并没有被谈论。这是英语老师薇薇安·布里辛（Vivian Bricksin）。
He talks about one student that tells them, "I don't think I want to do that," when he's trying to encourage them to work a little harder. And that is a kind of a surprising challenge to face as a teacher. "No, I don't think I want to do that." And the lack of motivation is a daily challenge, I think, for teachers in the school even if they're veterans.
他谈到了一个学生告诉他，“我不认为我想做那个”，当时他正试图鼓励他们更努力工作。作为一个老师，这是一个令人惊讶的挑战。“不，我不认为我想做那个。”我认为这种缺乏动力对于学校的老师来说是一个日常挑战，即使他们是资深老师。
Steve Poizner says, this is exactly what he hopes readers will take from his book. He wants it to lead to a better discussion about how to improve schools. In the book, he talks mostly about charter schools as being a good laboratory for new ideas.
史蒂夫·波兹纳说，这正是他希望读者从他的书中得到的。他希望这能引出关于如何改善学校的更好的讨论。在书中，他主要谈到了特许学校是新想法的良好实验室。
In his gubernatorial campaign, he also talks about cutting down on the central school bureaucracy in California, giving more control of the curriculum and more money to local schools, two things that teachers like, of course. Many of Mount Pleasant's teachers are less keen on two of Poizner's other big proposals, to make it easier to fire teachers and suspend rules at the bottom 40% of California schools and to expel from public schools all the students who are in the country illegally, which would, of course, affect students at Mount Pleasant.
在他的州长竞选中，他还谈到了削减加州的中央学校官僚机构，给予地方学校更多的课程控制权和更多的资金，当然，老师们喜欢这两点。许多芒特普莱森特的老师对波兹纳的其他两个大提案不那么热衷：让解雇老师变得更容易，暂停加州后40%学校的规则，以及将所有非法入境的学生从公立学校开除，这当然会影响芒特普莱森特的学生。
Poizner told me that, in the end, it doesn't matter if he got facts wrong about the school. Because everywhere, but at Mount Pleasant itself, this is the discussion that he hopes his book will engender.
波兹纳告诉我，归根结底，他是否在学校的事实上搞错了并不重要。因为除了芒特普莱森特本身，这是他希望他的书能激起的讨论。
Most Californians have absolutely no idea what goes on in a classroom, what goes on in the public education system. And so, at the end of it all, a month from now or a year from now, when people are debating this book, they're not going to be debating whether my characterization of the smells in the neighborhood are the same as yours when you went there. I mean, the purpose of the book is to improve the public education system.
大多数加州人根本不知道教室里发生了什么，公立教育系统里发生了什么。所以到最后，一个月后或一年后，当人们争论这本书时，他们不会争论我对社区气味的描述是否和你去那里时的一样。我的意思是，书的目的是改善公立教育系统。
English teacher Mark Holston sees this one differently. He says for Poizner to misread what this school and this neighborhood are all about says a lot about his judgment. And that does mean something.
英语老师马克·霍尔斯顿对此有不同的看法。他说波兹纳误读了这所学校和这个社区的意义，这充分说明了他的判断力。这确实意味着什么。
Half the state of California, who he's trying to represent, looks like our neighborhood. Our neighborhood looks more like California than the neighborhood he comes from. So I think he's completely out of touch. I hate to think that somebody, even getting this far, could be that naive, and be that clueless. That's even scarier. Because I'm sure he's going to run for something else. And he can't be that way off. It's terrifying he's that way off.
他试图代表的加州有一半的人口看起来就像我们的社区。我们的社区看起来比他出身的社区更像加州。所以我认为他完全脱离现实。我不愿去想，有人走到这一步，还能如此天真、如此无知。那更可怕。因为我敢肯定他会去竞选别的职位。他不能错得这么离谱。他错得这么离谱令人恐惧。
Again, this is an average high school. And if he was the governor, he'd be the chief educator for the state of California. And if he could misinterpret what he's sees in this school and portray a school as one of the toughest when it's an average high school in California, it's scary for our future in California if he ever got elected.
再说一次，这是一所普通的高中。如果他是州长，他就是加州首席教育长。如果他能误解他在学校所看到的一切，并将一所加州的普通高中描绘成最艰难的学校之一，那么如果他当选，我们加州的未来就可怕了。
One week after Poizner's book made it to number 5 on the best seller list, it dropped to number 33. The campaign declined to give sales figures for the book and declined to say whether it bought enough copies itself in that first week to put the book on the best seller list.
波兹纳的书进入畅销书排行榜第5名一周后，就跌到了第33名。竞选团队拒绝提供书籍的销售数字，也拒绝说明第一周是否自行购买了足够的副本以使该书进入畅销书排行榜。
The principal at Mount Pleasant told me she now finds herself with an awkward dilemma. Poizner has donated the profits from the book sales to the school. And she's not sure that they should take it. He got so many things wrong about Mount Pleasant and offended so many people. But at the same time, with budgets being slashed, it's hard for her to turn her back on any money that might help her students.
芒特普莱森特的校长告诉我，她现在陷入了一个尴尬的困境。波兹纳已经将售书利润捐给了学校。她不确定他们是否应该接受。他搞错了芒特普莱森特的太多事情，冒犯了太多人。但与此同时，随着预算被削减，她很难拒绝任何可能帮助学生的钱。
[MUSIC - "GANGSTA'S PARADISE" BY COOLIO]
[音乐 - 库利奥（Coolio）的《黑帮天堂》（GANGSTA'S PARADISE）]
Coming up, what refugees halfway around the world know about us thanks to Chevy Chase and other true urban legends. That's in a minute from Chicago Public Radio and Public Radio International when our program continues.
接下来，世界另一端的难民如何通过切维·切斯（Chevy Chase）和其他真实的都市传说了解我们。稍后将继续我们的节目，来自芝加哥公共广播电台和国际公共广播电台。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our show we choose a theme, bring you different kinds of stories on that theme. Today's show, True Urban Legends. We're wading into the vapory shadows of urban myth to see what is real and what is not. We've arrived at Act Two of our show. Act Two, Fleeing is Believing.
这里是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯（Ira Glass）。每周我们都会选择一个主题，带来不同类型的故事。今天的节目，《真实的都市传说》。我们正涉入都市神话的烟雾阴影中，看看什么是真实的，什么不是。我们现在进入了节目的第二幕。第二幕，《逃离即相信》。
Refugees often spend decades in camps waiting, waiting for wars to end back home, waiting to be resettled, some of them to the United States. This leaves a lot of time to think about what the future might hold and makes for a huge rumor mill fed by third cousins and friends of friends who get to the United States and send back word of what it's like. And that's where the confusion begins. Mary Wiltenburg, a reporter who has spent years documenting refugee life in America, has this story.
难民经常在难民营里等待几十年，等待家乡的战争结束，等待重新安置，一些人等待被安置到美国。这留下了大量时间去思考未来，并造就了一个巨大的谣言工厂，由表亲和朋友的朋友提供信息，他们先到了美国，然后传回那里的情况。困惑也就从这里开始。玛丽·威尔滕堡（Mary Wiltenburg），一位记录美国难民生活多年的记者，带了这一故事。
Say you're a refugee. Once you've survived whatever hell you fled plus 10 more years in a crowded camp, there are rumors about the US you want to believe. America is the land of easy money, endless food, plentiful jobs, machines that cook and clean for you. Still, it's not like you'll believe just anything. The refugees I've talked with say a lot of the rumors they hear seem way too far-fetched to be true.
假设你是一名难民。一旦你熬过了所逃离的地狱，再加上在拥挤的营地里度过的十年，就会有一些关于美国的谣言是你想要相信的。美国是容易赚钱、食物无尽、工作充足的地方，那里有为你做饭和打扫卫生的机器。不过，你也不会什么都信。我采访过的难民说，他们听到的很多谣言听起来太牵强了，不可能是真的。
Some people are very fat. You cannot imagine how fat they are.
有些人非常胖。你无法想象他们有多胖。
Kissing in public and all of that is normal. You shouldn't look. You shouldn't be surprised by it.
公共场合亲吻什么的都是正常的。你不应该看。你不应该对此感到惊讶。
When people grow old in America, as they become seniors, they send them to nursing homes to live in.
当人们在美国变老时，成为老年人时，他们会被送进疗养院居住。
When they go to the beach, they dress up in this swimsuit, which I call it underwear.
当他们去海滩时，他们穿着这种泳装，我称之为内衣。
In America, they say white people kiss their dogs, they hold it. And it's like, that is crazy. How can anybody kiss a dog?
在美国，他们说白人会亲吻他们的狗，抱着它们。这简直太疯狂了。怎么会有人亲吻狗呢？
What makes these rumors so unbelievable often is how inscrutable or frightening or taboo they would have been back home.
让这些谣言如此难以置信的原因，通常是因为在家乡这些行为是多么不可理解、可怕或禁忌。
I never, never thought people would show affection in public. It was just unbelievable.
我从没、从来没想过人们会在公共场合表现出亲密。那真是不可思议。
Faiza Mohamed is Somali and grew up as a refugee in Kenya where the whole idea of PDA was unimaginable especially among unmarried people. When refugees like her are accepted for resettlement in the US, they're bombarded with information about the country in these three-day orientation marathons that cover everything from fire safety to banking, sexual harassment to how to use an airplane toilet. Faiza's orientation leader actually mentioned that it's common for American couples to express affection in public.
法伊扎·穆罕默德（Faiza Mohamed）是索马里人，作为难民在肯尼亚长大，那里整个公共场合亲密行为的概念是不可想象的，尤其是在未婚男女之间。当像她这样的难民被接受安置在美国时，他们在这些为期三天的马拉松式入职指导中被狂轰滥炸，内容涵盖了从消防安全到银行、性骚扰到如何使用飞机马桶的所有知识。法伊扎的指导老师提到，美国夫妇在公共场合表达亲密是很常见的。
And did you believe it when I said it?
当我提到这一点时，你相信了吗？
No, because the person that was giving us the orientation was Somali herself. So I really didn't even think that she knew the reality of it.
没有，因为给我们做指导的人本身就是索马里人。所以我真的根本没认为她知道真实的现实。
Another problem is Hollywood, the source of some of the most enticing images of America and some of the most exaggerated. Sinisa Milovanovic, a refugee from the former Yugoslavia, spent years waiting in Germany before coming to the US. In Berlin one Christmas, a movie came on TV, National Lampoon's Christmas Vacation. In case you've been spared the pleasure, it features Chevy Chase as a guy who's, let's say, intense about seasonal decorating. He's covered every inch of his house with lights, nests of sparking extension cords, Santa-related [UNINTELLIGIBLE].
另一个问题是好莱坞，它是美国一些最诱人图像的来源，也是一些最夸张图像的来源。前南斯拉夫难民西尼萨·米洛瓦诺维奇（Sinisa Milovanovic）在来到美国前在德国等待了多年。在柏林的一个圣诞节，电视上播出了《疯狂圣诞假期》（National Lampoon's Christmas Vacation）。万一你没看过这部片子，主演切维·切斯扮演一个对节日装饰非常投入的家伙。他用灯光覆盖了房子的每一英寸，还有火花四溅的延长线巢，以及与圣诞老人相关的[听不清]。
We're going to have the best looking house in town, Russ.
我们要把房子装饰成镇上最好看的，拉斯。
Think you might be overdoing it, Dad?
爸，你是不是有点过度了？
And when you look at the spoof movies or comedies, they overblow out of the proportion many things just to make it funny. And when I saw it, I just thought, oh, this cannot be true. This is too much light.
当你看到那些恶搞电影或喜剧时，他们为了搞笑会把很多事情夸大。当我看到它时，我只是想，噢，这不可能是真的。这灯光也太多了。
That's a lot of lights, Dad.
那灯光可真不少，爸。
You want something you can be proud of, don't you?
你想要一个让你感到自豪的东西，不是吗？
A few after they watched this, Sinisa and his wife moved to Fargo, North Dakota. One night their first winter there, Sinisa got home, and his wife told him she had something to show him outside.
观看这部影片几年后，西尼萨和妻子搬到了北达科他州的法戈。那是他们在那里的第一个冬天，一个晚上，西尼萨回到家，妻子告诉他外面有东西要给他看。
And I didn't know what was it, so we got into the car, and we went around a couple of neighborhoods, residential area. And all of a sudden, I saw the whole row of houses. And to me, it seems like every single one of them had some kind of lights on it.
我不知道是什么，所以我们上了车，绕着几个街区转了转。突然之间，我看到了一整排房子。对我来说，看起来每一栋房子上面都挂着某种灯。
Oh Clark, it's so lovely.
噢克拉克，太可爱了。
And some people had not only the lights, but they also had the props, snowmen or reindeer and things like that. And we said to each other, they really do decorate their houses as Chevy Chase did.
有些人不仅有灯，还有道具，雪人、驯鹿之类的。我们对彼此说，他们真的像切维·切斯那样装饰他们的房子。
It's a beaut, Clark. It's a beaut.
真是漂亮，克拉克。真是漂亮。
You taught me everything I know about exterior illumination. Thank you. Thank you.
你教会了我关于室外照明的一切。谢谢。谢谢。
Even years later, former refugees recall these moments with incredible clarity. The shock or bewilderment or comedy of realizing, that's true? People here don't follow soccer? Men really date other men? Americans sleep in bed with their cats? A lot of times, the reaction is, whoa, OK. But once in a while, the moment changes a person's whole image of America.
即使多年后，前难民们依然能清晰地回忆起这些时刻。意识到“那是真的？”时的震惊、困惑或滑稽感。这里的人不看足球？男人真的和男人约会？美国人睡觉时和猫同床？很多时候，反应是“哇，好吧”。但偶尔，这一刻会改变一个人对美国的整个印象。
Hazem Taee, an Iraqi refugee, had heard back home that ordinary Americans could go into stores and buy guns. But that seemed incredible. How could a country keep law and order if its civilians were armed? Then one day, not long after his family arrived in Phoenix, they pulled up to a stoplight next to a guy on his motorcycle. He didn't look like a policeman, but for some reason he had a gun on his belt.
伊拉克难民哈泽姆·塔伊（Hazem Taee）在家乡时听说，普通的美国人可以进商店买枪。但这似乎令人难以置信。如果平民拥有武器，一个国家怎么能维持法律和秩序呢？后来有一天，在他们家到达菲尼克斯不久，他们在红灯处停下，旁边是一个骑摩托车的家伙。他看起来不像警察，但不知为什么，他的腰带上有一把枪。
We looked at him. He had a tattoo, a leather jacket with a bird on it on the back and a ponytail. He didn't look official to us.
我们看着他。他有纹身，穿着一件后面有鸟图案的皮夹克，扎着马尾辫。在我们看来，他看起来不像是官方人员。
Who were you with?
你当时和谁在一起？
Me, my wife, and three kids. And I'm advising them not to look, not to look, don't bring his attention, just take a quick look, and don't turn your face. And then, my kids started asking me, why would he have a gun, what is he planning to do? And I said, I don't know.
我，我的妻子和三个孩子。我建议他们不要看，不要看，别引起他的注意，只看一眼，别转头。然后，我的孩子们开始问我，为什么他会有枪，他打算做什么？我说，我不知道。
One especially scary rumor, one that refugees from all over the world told me they heard, but couldn't fathom, is that in America, people without homes sleep on the streets. When you come from someplace where it would be unthinkably shameful to let that happen to a relative, it's hard to believe. When Haider Hamza arrived in the US from Iraq four years ago, he was sure this was a myth. Then late one night, he went walking in Central Park.
一个特别可怕的谣言，一个来自世界各地的难民告诉我他们听过但无法理解的谣言是：在美国，无家可归的人睡在大街上。当你来自一个如果让亲戚发生这种事会感到极其羞耻的地方时，这很难相信。海德尔·哈姆扎（Haider Hamza）四年前从伊拉克来到美国时，他确信这是个神话。后来一个深夜，他在中央公园散步。
And there was a bench, and I saw an older woman not looking very happy, sleeping on that bench. And she looked in a pretty bad shape. So I got close, I tried talking to her. And she started asking for help and things like that. And I didn't know why she was there. I didn't know what happened, so I didn't know what to do.
有一条长椅，我看到一个看起来不太开心的老妇人睡在那张长椅上。她看起来处境很糟。所以我走近她，试着和她说话。她开始寻求帮助之类的。我不知道她为什么在那里。我不知道发生了什么，所以我不知道该怎么办。
I picked up the phone, I called 911. A lady answered, and I gave a description of the woman. And she said, "Well, is the woman bleeding?" And I went to check, and I said, "No, she's not." And so she said, "Is she naked?" I said, "No, actually." She paused for a second and said, "Well, is she homeless?" And I said, "I don't know." So I walked up to the woman, I said, "Excuse me, ma'am, are you homeless?" And she said, "Of course I'm homeless." So I got up on the phone and said, "Yes, she's homeless."
我拿起电话，拨打了911。一位女士接了电话，我描述了那位女士的情况。她说：“那个女人在流血吗？”我去检查了一下，说：“不，没有。”她说：“她裸体吗？”我说：“不，其实没有。”她沉默了一会儿说：“她是无家可归的吗？”我说：“我不知道。”所以我走到那个女人面前说：“打扰一下，女士，你是无家可归的吗？”她说：“我当然是无家可归的。”所以我回到电话上说：“是的，她是无家可归的。”
No matter who tells you that there are people who are homeless here in the United States, it's impossible to believe.
无论谁告诉你美国有无家可归的人，这都是不可能相信的。
That's Hazem, who saw the guy on the motorcycle with the gun. Now he works as a case manager at a resettlement agency, helping fellow refugees transition to American life. A couple of years ago, he told a group of clients that if they missed rent payments or couldn't find a job, they could wind up homeless and have to live in a shelter. They thought he was lying. Frustrated, he loaded them into a van and drove them past a homeless shelter in downtown Phoenix with a line out the door. They were shocked.
那就是哈泽姆，就是那个在摩托车上看到拿枪男人的家伙。现在他在一家重新安置机构担任个案经理，帮助同胞难民过渡到美国生活。几年前，他告诉一群客户，如果他们错过了租金或者找不到工作，他们可能会流落街头，不得不住在收容所里。他们以为他在撒谎。他感到很沮丧，于是把他们装进一辆面包车，开车带他们经过菲尼克斯市中心的一个收容所，那里排着长队。他们震惊了。
And they asked me what it is, "Are those really homeless people? And I said, "Yes, and you could easily lose your home or apartment. If you don't pay, you'll be evicted after a few months."
他们问我那是什么，“那些真的是无家可归的人吗？”我说，“是的，而且你很容易就会失去房子或公寓。如果你不付钱，几个月后你就会被赶出来。”
It happens so fast. You come here lost as can be and within a couple of years, you're the ambassador, the friend of a friend fielding calls from overseas in the middle of the night. You're showing around dazed new arrivals and watching their astonishment at the guns in Walmart, the dogs in handbags, the couples kissing in the park. And you're the one telling them, "Don't worry. Don't stare. That's normal here."
这一切发生得太快了。你来到这里时迷失方向，几年内，你就成了大使，成了朋友的朋友，在半夜处理海外打来的求助电话。你带领着那些不知所措的新来者，看着他们对沃尔玛里的枪、手提包里的狗、公园里接吻的情侣感到惊讶。而你就是那个告诉他们：“别担心。别盯着看。这里很正常。”
Mary Wiltenburg lives in Atlanta.
玛丽·威尔滕堡居住在亚特兰大。
[MUSIC - "BANKING ON A MYTH" BY ANDREW BIRD]
[音乐 - 安德鲁·伯德（Andrew Bird）的《押注神话》（BANKING ON A MYTH）]
Act 3, Sleeper Cells. The scariest urban myths are the ones that are about stuff that is everywhere, that we use every day, that we can't avoid, that our drinking water might be impure, that there are toxins in our food, that killer earthquakes might be coming to the west coast, that the polar ice caps might melt. Oh, wait a second, some of those are actually confirmed by scientists. Which brings me to cell phones.
第三幕，《沉睡细胞》。最可怕的都市传说往往是关于那些无处不在、我们每天都在使用、无法避免的东西；例如我们的饮用水可能不纯，我们的食物中有毒素，致命的地震可能袭击西海岸，极地冰盖可能融化。噢，等一下，其中一些已经被科学家证实了。这就把我们引向了手机。
There was an article in GQ Magazine recently about cell phones about whether they're bad for us. "The only honest way to think of our cell phones," the article says, "is that they are tiny, low-power microwave ovens, without walls, that we hold to the sides of our heads." Which is true. Cell phones and ovens both use the same kinds of waves, microwave frequencies. But, of course, microwave ovens use much, much, much more power, enough to cook meat.
最近《GQ》杂志上有一篇关于手机的文章，探讨它们是否对我们有害。“看待手机唯一诚实的方式是，”文章写道，“它们是微型的、低功率的微波炉，没有墙壁，我们把它们贴在头边。”这是真的。手机和微波炉都使用相同类型的波，即微波频率。当然，微波炉使用得更多、更多、多得多的功率，足以烹饪肉类。
And there's lots of research out there that's found no negative effects on our bodies from cell phones. In fact, there's another article in Harper's Magazine just this month about the same thing, are cell phones bad for us? And that article points out that for all the research that's found that cell phones make us lose sleep, make us think slower, break apart our DNA, cause brain damage in children, there are just as many studies, if not more, that say that cell phones make us more sleepy, make us think faster, don't break our DNA, and don't affect children one way or another.
现有的许多研究发现手机对我们的身体没有负面影响。事实上，就在本月《哈珀》杂志上还有另一篇关于同一件事的文章：手机对我们有害吗？文章指出，尽管所有的研究都发现手机让我们失眠、让我们思考变慢、破坏DNA、导致儿童脑损伤，但同样多甚至更多的研究表明，手机让我们更困倦、思考更快、不会破坏DNA，也不会以任何方式影响儿童。
Other countries, especially in Europe, take the possible threat of cell phones much more seriously than we do here in the US. Health ministries in Canada, Russia and Finland have asked for restrictions on sales of cell phones to children. France is trying to ban cell phones in schools. Some European governments are trying to ban wifi in government buildings and on campuses. Wifi also uses those microwave frequencies. And the National Library of France already got rid of it.
其他国家，特别是在欧洲，比我们美国更严肃地对待手机的潜在威胁。加拿大、俄罗斯和芬兰的卫生部已经要求限制向儿童销售手机。法国试图禁止在学校使用手机。一些欧洲政府试图在政府大楼和校园里禁用无线网络（wifi）。wifi也使用那些微波频率。法国国家图书馆已经取消了它。
People have protested and torn down cell towers in Spain, Ireland, Australia, and Israel. In 2007, the European Union's environmental agency warned that cell phone technology "could lead to a health crisis similar to those caused by asbestos, smoking, and lead in petrol." The operative word there, of course, is "could." The weird word is "petrol."
人们在西班牙、爱尔兰、澳大利亚和以色列抗议并拆毁了手机基站。2007年，欧盟环境署警告说，手机技术“可能导致类似由石棉、吸烟和汽油中的铅造成的健康危机”。当然，其中的关键动词是“可能”。奇怪的词是“汽油”（petrol）。
So what should we believe? Are they bad for us? Or aren't they? Christopher Ketcham, who wrote the GQ article, talked me through some of the most troubling studies.
所以我们应该相信什么？它们对我们有害吗？还是没害？克里斯托弗·凯彻姆（Christopher Ketcham），撰写了《GQ》文章的那个人，带我了解了一些最令人不安的研究。
Now in your article, you lay out a lot of data, a lot of studies. What's the most alarming evidence you have? Go ahead, scare us.
在你的文章中，你列出了很多数据，很多研究。你拥有的最令人担忧的证据是什么？来吧，吓吓我们。
All right. Well, there's a lot. There is something called Interphone, which is a 13-country study, European wide and also including Israel, that has been looking at the incidence of brain tumors and tumors generally as related to cell phone use. And the big conclusion from that study is that for those users of cell phones who use cell phones for 10 years or more on the same side of the head, there's a 40% increased chance of getting a brain tumor.
好的。嗯，有很多。有一个叫“Interphone”的研究，这是一个跨越13个国家（包括以色列）的研究，它一直在观察脑瘤和肿瘤发生率与手机使用的关系。该研究得出的重大结论是，对于那些使用手机10年或以上，且在头部同一侧使用手机的人来说，患脑瘤的几率增加了40%。
A brain tumor on that side of the head?
头部那一侧的脑瘤？
On that side of the head. Probably shaped like a cell phone. So the--
在那一侧。可能形状像手机。所以……
All right. That last part you're just making up.
好了。最后那部分是你编的吧。
I'm  just making it up. I'm just making it up. There is an independent Swedish study a couple of years ago found that there was a 420% increased chance of getting brain tumors for those who were using cell phones at age 20 or earlier.
我确实是编的。我确实是编的。几年前有一项独立的瑞典研究发现，对于那些在20岁或更早年龄使用手机的人，患脑瘤的几率增加了420%。
So four times more chances?
所以几率高了四倍？
Yeah, four times more. The speculation is that this is because children's or young people's brains are not fully formed. Their skulls are thinner so that they absorb more radiation. Allan Frey, the neuroscientist who, in many ways, shepherded me through a lot of the early studies, when he was working for the Office of Naval Research in the 1970s, he found that cell-phone-type radiation could cause blood brain barrier leakage. That is, it could cause perforations in the barrier between the circulatory system and the brain. Now that's really bad news.
是的，四倍多。推测这是因为儿童或年轻人的大脑还没有完全发育。他们的头骨更薄，所以吸收更多的辐射。艾伦·弗雷（Allan Frey），那位在许多方面指引我了解早期研究的神经科学家，当他在1970年代为海军研究办公室工作时，他发现手机类辐射可能导致血脑屏障渗漏。也就是说，它可能导致循环系统和大脑之间的屏障出现穿孔。那可是非常坏的消息。
OK, give me another.
好的，再给我一个。
Well, for example, a researcher biologist named Henry Lai at the University of Washington found that after two hours of exposure to microwave frequencies--
嗯，例如，华盛顿大学的一位生物学家亨利·莱（Henry Lai）发现，在接触微波频率两小时后……
At the level that comes out of a cell phone.
达到手机发出的水平。
At the level that comes out of a cell phone, you can have DNA damage. After two hours, it's double-strand breakage in DNA.
达到手机发出的水平，你可能会出现DNA损伤。两小时后，会导致DNA双链断裂。
Now so these are the studies that show that we do have reason to worry. Aren't there a lot of other studies on the other side saying, like, no, no, no, we don't have to worry.
所以这些研究表明我们确实有担心的理由。难道没有很多其他研究在另一边说，不，不，不，我们不需要担心吗？
Oh yeah, there are lots and lots of studies showing that. And the really interesting thing to me is that if you divide the many, many studies on this subject about the biological effects of cell phones radiation--
噢，是的，有很多很多研究显示这一点。对我来说真正有趣的是，如果你把关于手机辐射生物效应的大量研究分开来看……
And it's hundreds of studies, right?
而且有几百项研究，对吧？
It's hundreds of studies, hundreds of studies over the years. When you look at these studies and divide them by funding, you'll find that 75% of those studies that were independently funded-- that is, that had no funding from industry--
是几百项研究，多年来几百项研究。当你查看这些研究并按资助来源划分时，你会发现，那些独立资助的研究中——也就是说，没有来自行业资助的——75%显示出某种影响。这些研究……
From the cell phone business, yeah.
等等，等等。让我……所以换句话说，如果没有任何来自电话公司或与之相关的人的资助，75%的研究表明，是的，手机发出的电磁信号确实会影响我们的细胞。它们具有生物学效应。好的。
The Nokias, the Ericssons, just the telecom industry generally. You find that 75% of those studies show some type of effect. Those studies--
是诺基亚、爱立信，电信行业通常都是这样。是的。现在，如果你把由行业资助的研究汇总起来，你会发现只有25%的研究显示出生物学效应。所以似乎存在——在接受我采访的科学家中也存在争论——似乎存在一种与资金来源有关的数据倾斜。
Wait, wait. Let me just-- So in other words, if there's no funding from telephone companies or people associated with them, 75% of the studies show, yes, the electromagnetic signals out of cell phones actually do affect our cells. They have a biological effect. OK.
好吧，环保局（EPA）曾经研究过这类辐射的环境影响。但你是对的，它停止了。谈谈为什么它停止了。
Yes. Now if you pool the studies that are funded by the industry, you find that only 25% of those studies show a biological effect. So there appears to be-- and the argument has been among the scientists who I interviewed-- there appears to be a skewing, a data skewing, that is related to the source of funding.
嗯，发生的情况是，在1970年代，对微波辐射的生物效应进行了严格的实验室研究。环保局在这方面走在前面。你还有国家职业安全与健康研究所（NIOSH）。
Now the EPA used to look into this to see the environmental effect of this kind of radiation. But you're right that it stopped. Talk about why it stopped.
国家职业安全与健康研究所？
Well, what happened is in the 1970s, there was serious laboratory research into the biological effects of microwave radiation. EPA was foremost in this. You also had NIOSH.
是的。还有食品药品监督管理局（FDA）。这些都是研究这些效应的机构。然后里根政府上台，星球大战，这些巨大的雷达操作……
National Institute of Occupational Safety and Health?
这都是1980年代的事了，是的。
Yes. And also FDA, Food and Drug Administration. These were all agencies that were studying these effects. And then the Reagan administration came into office, Star Wars, these huge radar-operated--
这都是1980年代的事了。雷达操作的导弹防御系统即将实施。军事利益相关者——西屋电气、波音公司和那些生产各种军事雷达系统的巨头——联手军方，向国会施压，迫使环保局停止这类研究。
This is all the 1980s, yeah.
这就是环保局内部消息来源告诉你的？
This is all the 1980s. Radar-operated missile defense systems were to be implemented. And military interests-- Westinghouse and Boeing and huge-- that produce all sorts of the radar systems for the military-- along with the military pressured Congress to pressure EPA to stop this kind of research.
是的，这就是环保局内部消息来源说的。资金从环保局撤走了。资金从FDA撤走了。那些负责研究这些问题的文职科学家被告知，听着，你们不需要再调查这个了，我们将由空军来处理。
This is what your sources inside the EPA told you?
那么现在，哪个联邦机构负责确保我们的手机不会杀死我们？
Yes, this is what my sources inside the EPA said. And funding was taken away from the EPA. Funding was taken away from the FDA. And those researchers, those civilian scientists who were looking into this, were told, listen you don't need to look into this anymore, we're going to handle it in the Air Force.
联邦通信委员会（FCC）。但路易斯·斯莱辛（Louis Slesin）告诉我……
And right now, which federal agency is responsible for making sure that our cell phones aren't killing us?
斯莱辛是谁？
The FCC. But Louis Slesin told me--
路易斯·斯莱辛是《微波新闻》（Microwave News）的出版人。我认为他是各种研究方面的权威专家之一。让我读读他说的。他说：“历史上，制定电磁安全标准的委员会一直由来自军方的代表、像雷神公司（Raytheon）和通用电气这样的公司、电信公司以及现在的手机行业所主导。”斯莱辛告诉我，这基本上是私营部门操纵公共政策的特洛伊木马。
And Slesin is?
好的。所以我记得手机刚出来的时候，有关于它们是否有害、是否可能导致脑瘤的恐慌故事。那时候90年代，一切都非常具有推测性。然后似乎那些故事消失了。而我，作为一个只是看新闻的人，我只是认为，好吧，我想这意味着没什么可担心的。你是说，是的，我们现在知道手机确实会给我们带来脑瘤吗？还是说，是的，我们现在知道我们需要担心，因为没有足够的研究来确定它们是安全的？
Louis Slesin is the publisher of Microwave News. He's, I think, one of the foremost experts on the various studies. Let me just read what he said. He said, "The committees setting the EM-- the electromagnetic-- safety levels historically have been dominated by representatives from the military, by companies like Raytheon and General Electric, by the telecom companies, and now by the cell phone industry." Slesin tells me that it is basically a Trojan horse for the private sector to dictate public policy.
后者。听着，即使是FDA也会告诉你。他们关于这个问题的官方通知是，我们，FDA，不确定这些设备的安全性。但与此同时，FDA会说，但似乎也没有风险。所以他们保持中立。
OK. So I remember when cell phones first came out, and there were scare stories about whether or not they were harmful and whether they might cause brain tumors. And at that point in the '90s, it was all very speculative. And then it seemed like those stories went away. And I, as somebody just like reading the news, I just thought like, well, I guess that means that there's nothing to worry about. Are you saying, yes, we now know cell phones do give us brain tumors? Or are you saying, yes, we now know we need to worry that there's not enough research to know they're safe?
所以如果安全性不明确，但他们却有数以亿计的产品在使用，所以这就像一个巨大的科学实验。
The latter. Listen, even the FDA will tell you. Their official notice on this issue is that we, the FDA, are not certain about the safety of these devices. But at the same time, the FDA will say, but, there doesn't appear to be a risk either. So they hedge it.
巨大的科学实验。我采访的科学家之一，莱夫·萨尔福德（Leif Salford），那位瑞典神经科学家说，这是有史以来最大的人类生物实验，因为我们真的不知道会有什么影响，长期影响会是什么，短期影响会是什么。
So if the safety isn't clear, but then they have like hundreds of millions of them out being used, so it's just like a big science experiment.
这是那种我们不知道答案，但很多人正在研究，投入了大量资金来找出答案的事情吗？还是那种我们不知道答案，而实际上没有人——投入的资金不多来找出答案的事情？
Huge science experiment. One of the scientists who I interviewed, Leif Salford, this Swedish neuroscientist, said, This is the largest human biological experiment ever because we really don't know what the effects are going to be, what the long-term effects are going to be, what the short-term effects are going to be.
在这个国家，几乎……什么都没在进行。几乎没有研究。在欧洲，有很多研究。在以色列，那是人均手机使用量最高的国家之一，有很多研究。在瑞典，爱立信的故乡，有很多研究。
And is this one of these things where we don't know the answer, but lots of people are looking into it, and a lot of money is going into it to figure this out? Or is this one of these things where we don't know the answer? And really nobody-- like, not much money is really going into this to figure this out?
你当初是怎么接触到这个主题的？你认识某人吗——你是怎么接触到这个的？
In this country, there is almost-- there is nothing is going on. There's just almost no research. In Europe, there's a lot of research. In Israel, which has one of the highest per capita uses of cell phones, there's a lot of research. In Sweden, home of Ericsson, a lot of research.
我女儿的祖母在法国巴黎给她买了一部手机。与此同时，我在《世界报》（Le Monde）上看到了一条关于手机潜在风险的小通知，那是一条埋在报纸深处的极小极小的通知。我说，等一下，让我开始研究这个。
Now how did you get into the subject? Did you know somebody who-- How did you get into this?
鉴于你所了解的一切，你的女儿是青少年吗？
My daughter's grandmother bought her a cell phone in France, in Paris. And at the same time, I saw a little notice in Le Monde about-- it was a little, tiny notice buried deep in the paper about possible risks from cell phones. And I said, wait a minute, let me start looking into this.
她14岁。
And given all that you've learned, have-- your daughter is a teenager?
那你试过劝她不要用手机吗？
She's 14.
噢，我一直在和她谈。我一直在对她大吼大叫。
So have you tried to talk her into not using her cell phone?
效果如何？
Oh, I talk to her all the time. I'm always yelling at her.
很差。
And how does that go?
[笑声]
Badly.
她现在最常用来发短信。但有时我抓到她在用。我非常生气。我说：“不，如果你要用它，你必须用免提电话。如果你要把它放在身体附近，它必须关机。”
[LAUGHTER]
你觉得她相信你说手机很危险吗？
She now uses it to text most often. But sometimes I catch her on it. And I get really pissed off. And that is, I catch her with it to her ear. And I say, "No, if you're going to use it, you have to use your speaker phone. If you're going to keep it near your body, it has to be off."
我不确定。我不确定。这就是问题所在。我不知道她是否相信我。
Well, do you think that she believes you that the cell phone is dangerous?
鉴于你在自己的孩子身上取得的“成功”，你觉得你通过写文章并说服其他人放下手机的成功机会有多大？
I'm not sure. I'm not sure. That's the problem. I don't know if she believes me.
噢，大多数人觉得我疯了。大多数人觉得我完全是个疯子。他们直接无视我要说的话。
And so, given your success with your own child, how do you feel about your chances of success writing articles and convincing other people to put down their cell phones?
无视，就像甚至不听证据吗？
Oh, most people think I'm crazy. Most people think I'm absolutely bonkers. They just dismiss outright what I have to say.
不，他们会听证据。然后他们会用手机打电话给朋友告诉他们这件事。这就像……
Dismiss it like won't even listen to the evidence?
[笑声]
No, they will listen to the evidence. And then they'll call their friend to tell them about it on their cell phone. It's like--
所以，你知道，他们不在乎。他们只是……有一次我在电梯里下来，有个家伙在手机上狂敲，然后放在耳边。我提了一句。
[LAUGHTER]
你说了什么？等等，你说了什么？
So, you know, they don't care. They just-- One time I was in an elevator coming down, and some guy was pecking away on his cell phone, then put it to his head. And I mentioned it.
我对他说：“你知道那个设备对你来说可能非常危险。”我不知道我为什么要那么说。我想我只是在多管闲事，很烦人……整个车厢的人都开始笑了。他们只是开始笑。他们就像，是的，是的，你知道。我想他们是在嘲笑我。
What did you say? Wait, what did you say?
克里斯托弗·凯彻姆是一位调查记者。我们的网站上有他《GQ》文章的链接。
I said to him, "You know that device could be very dangerous for you." And I don't know why I said that. I guess I was just being nosy and being tiresome and-- And the whole car just started laughing. They just start laughing. They're like, yeah, yeah, you know. And I think they were laughing at me.
[音乐 - 兄弟阿里（Brother Ali）的《真相是》（TRUTH IS）]
Christopher Ketcham is an investigative reporter. We linked to his GQ article at our website.
我们的节目今天由莎拉·柯尼格（Sarah Koenig）制作，亚历克斯·布隆伯格（Alex Blumberg）、本·卡尔霍恩（Ben Calhoun）、简·费尔特斯（Jane Feltes）、丽莎·波拉克（Lisa Pollak）、罗宾·塞米恩（Robyn Semien）、阿丽莎·希普（Alissa Shipp）和南希·厄普代克（Nancy Updike）协助。我们的高级制片人是朱莉·斯奈德（Julie Snyder）。塞斯·林德（Seth Lind）是我们的制作经理。艾米丽·康顿（Emily Condon）是我们的办公室经理。布莱恩·里德（Brian Reed）提供了制作帮助。
[MUSIC - "TRUTH IS" BY BROTHER ALI]
[致谢]
Our program is produced today by Sarah Koenig with Alex Blumberg, Ben Calhoun, Jane Feltes, Lisa Pollak, Robyn Semien, Alissa Shipp, and Nancy Updike. Our senior producer is Julie Snyder. Seth Lind is our production manager. Emily Condon is our office manager. Production help from Brian Reed.
我们的网站，thisamericanlife.org。本周，你可以看到我们认为与史蒂夫·波兹纳在芒特普莱森特的发现相矛盾的原始数据。《美国生活》由国际公共广播电台发行。我们节目的WBEZ管理监督由我们的老板托雷·马拉蒂亚（Torey Malatia）先生负责，他希望我们WBEZ的每个人都回到锻炼计划中，回到楼梯机上。夏天就要来了。
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
有些人非常胖。你无法想象他们有多胖。
Our website, thisamericanlife.org. For this week, you can see the raw data that we think contradicts Steve Poizner's findings at Mount Pleasant. This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International. WBEZ management oversight for our program by our boss Mr. Torey Malatia, who wants all of us here at WBEZ to get back to our exercise programs, back on the stair machine. Summer is coming.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周再带来更多《美国生活》的故事。
Some people are very fat. You cannot imagine how fat they are.
[音乐 - 兄弟阿里（Brother Ali）的《真相是》（TRUTH IS）]
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
PRI，国际公共广播电台。
[MUSIC - "TRUTH IS" BY BROTHER ALI]
[音乐 - BROTHER ALI 演唱的 "TRUTH IS"]
PRI, Public Radio International.
PRI，公共广播国际。